let's bring out Kaitlyn she is a
contributing editor for The Atlantic
Monthly whose new cover story is that's
not funny how today's college students
can't seem to take a joke
please welcome Kaitlyn Flanagan well
what a time to have the name Caitlyn is
really I'm calling for you yeah what
probably wasn't a problem for like the
first 20-something years of your life
other problems with it but this is a new
dimension I know okay well we won't talk
about that I really wanted a Buick is
when I read your article I said oh my
gosh
this is the person who's going to
continue this discussion I started well
I didn't start some other people did
I've mentioned it before about how
college kids have no sense of humor than
Jerry Seinfeld said something Chris Rock
chimed in Larry the Cable Guy said I
don't play colleges anymore they're too
politically correct you delve into why
so I really want you to explain it why
are the college students so politically
correct why there's no political correct
now well they're their inheritors of 30
years of identity politics and that's
that's part of the problem what is that
that means that you know instead of
saying we all have general principles by
which we live and seek to sort of
understand our lives that I'm going to
stand up for the feminist cause I'm
going to stand up for a particular
racial or ethnic cause and I'm going to
fiercely guard that and completely stand
on the side of that issue tribal yes it
is rather tribal aren't we and I think
that you know it's it's I don't blame
the kids for this a lot of people really
demonize the kids the parents right I
think so because you know when kids come
to college when they come to any school
they are you know by definition they're
ignorant they don't know anything yet
and it is the moral obligation of their
teachers of the adults who work in that
institution to teach them something to
relieve them of this great burden of
ignorance but there are so many
professors who have completely abdicated
that position and have just cravenly
seated to whatever these poor kids who
don't know anything yet what they come
and say that is reinforced by the
professors and the whole system is now
being run by these kids who are paying
reparations that pay to sell well that's
a great point that you make that are
are probably our idea you and I of
college is outdated we thought it was an
institution where you learn and explore
and it's really all about keeping the
kids paying the tuition it is it's
become a Country Club right spend a
tremendous amount of money which many of
them can't afford that's sort of an
immoral aspect of it as well they kind
of lure these kids in with their
wonderful gems and their farm to table
dining and their idiot politically
correct sort of you know humanities
curriculum and the kids end up with
these staggering debts that they have to
somehow pay off and with this ridiculous
sort of sense of you know I'm not saying
that the idea is that each of them hold
is necessarily a bad idea but when we
were young you know I grew up in
Berkeley and you know I saw my father's
a college professor the kids who had you
know really progressive ideas they had
skin in the game they were getting
estranged from their parents they were
leaving school they were eating kind of
brown rice in apartments around Berkeley
they were paying a tremendous personal
cost for these political beliefs but
nowadays these kids mom and dad write
huge checks they're extremely privileged
they're extremely pampered and they run
around complaining that they're the
victim of these microaggressions right
yes they need trigger warnings in case
someone says something awful and they
think that we're sort of these these
horrible craftspeople who don't
understand the great beauty of life that
they do and that we don't understand
when we're giving microaggressions
against them right but if you and I went
to the South Bronx and we found some 19
year olds there and we said how much of
your day do you spend worrying about
microaggressions right
they wouldn't know whether to laugh why
because they know that we live in a
violent country with a gun problem yes
you know who else doesn't care about
them Doctors Without Borders because
they're actually doing something to help
the world right not just sitting on the
internet like you know virtual
vigilantes pointing out the bad person
exactly and again I don't hold them
responsible it's it's the nature of you
that you don't know much yet right but
the people who teach there should be
instructing them that they should have
free speech they should have an ability
to inquire they should be able to ask
any question they should be able to
write anything and subject themselves to
to the academic of rigorous intellectual
discipline and that's largely gone
you